through it all Jennifer was a victim as
well as a villain she didn't ask to be
turned into a succubus and all of the
strange behavior that followed
represents her going through the changes
that come with puberty and adulthood but
because she's not ready for any of that
she doesn't handle it well at all you
could say that her maturity was stunted
that day when L shoulder took advantage
of her something that we've talked about
before when discussing victims of trauma
on Horror history abuse neglect exposure
to violence lack of attachment and other
adverse childhood experiences affect the
structure and chemistry of the brain and
can stunt its natural grow growth and
maturation these negative experiences
have an effect not only in childhood but
throughout life adult relationships
grief and the dissolution of childhood
friendships are just a few of the
challenges that she does a very poor job
of coping with that's my analysis of the
character and I pretty much know that it
is correct not only because screenwriter
Diablo Cody and I are practically the
same person but because she's actually
spoken about the themes of Jennifer's
Body in interviews the theme of
Jennifer's Body said Cody is about the
horror of being a teenager